foreign
North Carolina hi Virginia welcome to
the Ramsay show
hi guys thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
heartbroken
about a situation with his family and
I'm struggling with feeling guilty about
feeling resentful and then I'm you know
kind of like seeing things that are just
not nice and it's it's putting a strain
on a relationship and it makes me just
want to
give up but I don't want to give up
because I love them so much and
what's what's the situation
but his parents moved in with him a few
years ago to help after a devastating
divorce and
and now
we've been dating for
like but you know
kind of like they're going to be
permanently there and he feels obligated
to continue supporting them because you
know they kind of sold everything to go
help them and I just don't know if
we were talking about marriage and
starting life together and I don't know
if he'll ever really be able to let go
of that and be focused on a household we
would create together
you know because he would maybe let's
say if he moved out and maybe charged
them rent or something but it wouldn't
cover you know any of the expenses so
most so about let's let's stop talking
let's stop talking about him okay
what kind of Life do you want
do you let me let me tell you this
before you answer it it's okay to say I
want to be married
to somebody and nobody else lives in our
house for a while
I want to fill in the blank which by the
way would be pretty normal yeah
um I I
what do you want
that
marriage picture where it's two people
and it's even if it's a blended family
that it's you know because that's what
we both we both have kids you know that
we'd be bringing into it and that's hard
enough without everything else and and I
really we each don't by ourselves make a
lot of money and it's not about the
money but it's just if we were to
combine forces we could really get ahead
and change our family tree and and it's
just so you know what you want exactly
that's what I want and and I think he's
said he's willing to you know let's say
even if he lets him stay living there at
his house but it would still be kind of
like
he'd probably still have to support a
lot you know because they can't really
afford to pay did you get hurt in your
first marriage
you're not done there
what you're trying to do is you're
trying to get back out there quote
unquote you found somebody you like this
guy you started making plans and
thinking about tomorrow which you
haven't done in a while
and your body is saying hey we've done
this before and it almost got us killed
and the way you're trying to solve that
angst and that fear is by controlling
every future variable down the road
and what I want to tell you is you can't
do that you're going to make yourself
nuts
because you could marry somebody in two
months in it's you all have this nice
small little house in your and you are
changing your family tree and then his
dad passes away and mom has to go like
life just happens
or he gets hit by a butt like this is
life the difference between you dating
right now is you know up front what
you're what you're walking into
and so you're gonna have to
as scary as it is put yourself out there
to get hurt again that's the only way
relationships work you got to go all in
or say
here's what I want here's what I need if
you can't do that if you're not
interested in that that's gonna hurt
like bloody hell and
that's what grief is and then we're
gonna pick up pick it up and we're gonna
go figure out something else
you're trying to do it all you can't I
can hear it how you talk it's all just
chaos in there right so with him
comes a package
you can't control
the package he's got kids he's got
parents in his house
you can't control that
and he's got values that say I do this
and I do this and I do this and I'm
going to do this
it's in there too it's kind of obvious
where this is going to go
so you're you're either going to sign up
for that
and be happy about it or you're going to
say you know that's not the picture I've
got I don't want to do that
now I want to be fair to him have you
sat down and been very clear
I am not interested in moving forward in
this relationship
If this relationship is going to include
x y and z
looked like if we were to try to start a
home together
um
I think he kind of more says don't worry
about it it'll all work out nope and I'm
wanting more it won't no it won't nope
because his didn't work out
so uh I'm confused they moved in with
him to help him after the divorce but
now they're the ones that need help
that's yeah that's kind of like my issue
is I feel like well they didn't you know
they were fine before and I know they
missed out on all that you know house
boom and everything whereas if they kept
their house they could have had a lot of
equity and then they missed out on all
that so now they really don't have
anything so they did really give up
everything to you know and they probably
so the house that he's in he owns and
they're living with him can he just give
him that house
I I think that would be beautiful and
essentially he probably in in effect
would be but no I don't I wouldn't do it
in effect I would just say you're on
your own you stand on your own two feet
you're like grown people now and here's
your house here's a house I'm marrying
her I'm moving into her place
and y'all y'all y'all got to figure it
out because you're going to pay the
bills over here
no they how old are these people
okay and they have no money
they didn't move in with him to help him
they moved in with him because they were
broke
I don't know well I'm telling you I mean
they didn't go from Rich to broke while
living in a free house
it worked before but then they were able
to retire when they moved in kind of
thing
and that's good I'm glad they can do
that it's just that now I do struggle
thinking wait like you said wait they
didn't help before but now they're
dependent on you you know here's the big
picture you were spending a lot of time
in his head and in their head get out
get out of their heads
the rent's too expensive yeah you've got
to sit down and say here's what I want
here's what I need
and is that is that a picture you can go
with if you can't then um this hurts but
oh we can't do this and it's going to be
it's gonna be treadful and heartbreaking
if you get hurt again
but better now than than getting into
this because you're going to spend your
whole life but you're pissed off right
you're really angry
and I don't want to be that guy
I know I know but you're looking at this
and you're going this is cray-cray and I
can see cray-cray a mile away and I
don't want to do it and it's making you
angry I don't really I'm not saying I
blame you but no I don't blame you at
all you're working awfully hard to make
anger sound sweet but and also you know
this situation makes you angry and you
keep going back into it yeah so you're
gonna sit down with him and go look if
this I've got to have some boundaries
here with you and with your parents for
me to be able to function in this
otherwise it doesn't feel right to me
I'm not going to be able to go forward
yeah and you gotta you gotta heal from
your old divorce yeah big time and if
you haven't sat down and and
with a good counselor yeah with a good
counselor for sure but you haven't sat
down and written your old self a letter
says
to your to you
I got hurt real bad and just lay that
stuff out there because your body's
still trying to solve for it lay it out
there
and say here's what I want moving
forward and then if this guy isn't that
guy then that so be it there's gonna be
somebody else out there
it's a mess
so thanks for calling Virginia what's
the probability John that um
that it's uh her woundedness
that it he's probably that he could be
thinking real clearly that he's going to
be have good boundaries with his parents
and but her woundedness has just got her
freaked out about it the possibility I
think if she is she's so terrified that
if I say exactly what I need if I put my
boundaries down he might go yeah and
she's experienced that loss before so
she's willing to give up her Integrity
who she wants to be she doesn't want to
be an angry person she said I want to be
a sweet person she's giving all that up
because she doesn't want to get left